MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
IKAI LAN: Afternoon,
developers.
We are here to welcome you
today to September 20th
edition of Google Developers
Live for Google Apps Script.
My name is Ikai Lan.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I'm
Eric Koleda.
IKAI LAN: And we've got a good
show for you guys today.
So we're going to recap the
Austin Hackathon, which
happened last week.
Eric's going to show us a really
cool app he's been
working on.
It integrates Google+ and
Google Apps Script.
And after that, we're going to
go ahead and answer some live
questions, as well some of the
questions on Google Moderator.
So first off, let's
talk about Austin.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh, that
was a blast.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, Eric and I
were in Austin last week
hosting Hackathon.
At the Hackathon, we had a lot
of really great participants.
So if any of you guys are
watching right now, you guys
were awesome.
We had a great time
[? in a U-Haul. ?]
Right?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, no,
it was a blast.
We had a lot of excitement
out there.
People who really ranged the
spectrum too of existing Apps
Script developers, to people who
are brand new to it, some
students, some people
from enterprises.
It was great.
IKAI LAN: We saw pretty good
apps that got built.
There's one guy, he uses Google
Drive to store all of
his invoices.
His name is Will.
And what he does is he put
together an app script that
goes through entire Google Drive
and pulls out all the
spreadsheets and it builds a
dashboard that tells him how
much money he's been making.
And it was kind of funny
because he demoed this
application to a live audience
with his live data.
And he's like, this is how
much cash flow I have.
I was like, oh that's
good, that's good.
But he was a really cool guy.
I really had a good time
talking to him.
ERIC KOLEDA: We embrace openness
here at Google, so
you know, I think it
fit with the event.
IKAI LAN: Here's my pin
number, by the way.
We had this other guy who,
he worked for the
government, I believe.
And I was super impressed
by the app.
Now, he was probably the only
guy who had Apps Script
experience.
And what he built was an
application, it was a
combination of Apps Script and
Fusion Tables, that everybody
riding in a squad car, or a
fire engine, would have a
laptop with a 3G connection.
And what happened was, you could
look at it at any given
time, you could look on a map
and see where are all the
other squad cars, where
are the fire engines.
And he was doing was doing
some really cool stuff.
ERIC KOLEDA: I love seeing that
integration with Fusion
Tables too.
With ScriptDb we've got this new
way of storing data, but
Fusion Tables is great,
especially if he has a lot of
relational things.
So I think it really worked
well for him.
It was all the Geo stuff, and
the ScriptDb-- he showed me
all the stuff, I was like oh
my god, you built all that?
He goes, oh actually,
I uh, ScriptDb, I
used the Fusion Tables.
Oh, that reminds me, there was
another really cool app that
we saw that was demoed.
Who was the one guy who, it was
a Google map and-- do you
remember this?
It was a document where if
I sent you five points of
interest, it would find the
shortest path to all these
things and it will email
you directions.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I think he
was imagining a delivery
person having to make five
different deliveries, what's
the best route?
IKAI LAN: Right, that was a
really good application.
And I remember, there were some
comments, they were from
me about, holy moly so you have
these points, find me the
shortest path to all
of these points.
And he goes, actually I just
called it the Optimize Route.
We have that, that's awesome.
ERIC KOLEDA: Google Maps, in
Apps Script, the direction
finder has this great
feature, Optimize.
One flag, you're done.
IKAI LAN: Right.
For everyone that's studied
computer science before,
mathematics, you know that this
is something called the
traveling salesman problem.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's not
easily solved.
Not easy, but somebody did it.
And you can take advantage
of it.
Overall, I had a great
time in Austin.
What did you think?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I had a
blast out there, as well.
I mean, a really good
environment in the room.
People were excited.
They had a lot of fun, too.
I think people were really
impressed at how much they
could get done during
the short amount
of time of a Hackathon.
Because there wasn't a need to
set up an environment, we
didn't have to guide people
through getting Eclipse
configured correctly, they just
opened their browser, and
they were going straight away.
IKAI LAN: Eric, I mean Eric was
like that, he was on top
of everything.
Like this, this is my
on top of stuff.
One thing I had tried to do when
I was in Austin was, I
tried to go visit this barbecue
place, and I tried to
get Eric to come with me, but
he just wouldn't do it.
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, I had
barbecue at the airport.
I know that doesn't sound right,
but it was actually
like a legitimate joint that
had an outpost there.
IKAI LAN: Legitimate?
Franklin Barbecue
is legitimate.
ERIC KOLEDA: No, no,
I would have gone.
This wasn't like Joe's Wild West
Barbecue in the airport,
this was a real Austin place.
IKAI LAN: Oh, it was the place
that Mike recommended.
ERIC KOLEDA: Exactly.
IKAI LAN: Salt Lick.
ERIC KOLEDA: Salt Lick.
IKAI LAN: So I will say, Austin
barbecue is legit and
so are Austin developers.
So, thank you guys
for having us.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I think we're
looking to do some more
Hackathons in the future.
IKAI LAN: Look forward
to announcements.
ERIC KOLEDA: Coming soon.
IKAI LAN: They're coming soon.
So I think that's enough of
us just talking about how
awesome Austin is.
I think so.
Eric has an application he's
been working on that
he'd like to demo.
So Eric, why don't
you take it away.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, sure.
With Google I/O this year, we
launched the ability to create
web apps in Apps Script.
You can publish as a web app,
use the user's credentials in
order to make calls to Google
services, publish straight to
the Chrome Web Store from within
Google Apps Script.
So we've been working here, on
the Developer Relations Team,
to build some sample apps to
kind of demonstrate what's
possible, and get people excited
about building apps in
Apps Script.
So the app I've built is
lovingly called Feed Plus.
And the concept is
pretty similar.
I don't know, I'm a Google+
power user.
IKAI LAN: Power user?
What does that mean?
ERIC KOLEDA: It means I'm on
there multiple times a day.
So I use it a lot.
And I also use it to keep track
of what other people are
doing with Apps Script.
So what I really wanted was a
way to kind of track new posts
about Google+ activity
that was going on.
And for me, the natural
interface was Google Reader.
That's where I spent a lot of
my time, also monitoring
different things.
So I created an app that allows
you to take Google+
activities, and turn it
into an RSS feed that
you can add to Reader.
So this is great, because it
demonstrates and utilizes a
few different things in the
Google Apps Script set of APIs
that we have, that
are pretty cool.
Let's start by demoing what it
looks like and how you use it.
So I'm zoomed in super far here,
so all you're seeing is
a giant white screen.
But there's not much outside
that anyway.
So it gives you the option to
create a feed out of either a
users public profile, it's all
the things that the post
publicly, not any private or
things shared just with
circles, or search results,
which is what I like to use.
So for instance, if I search
for Apps Script, and hit
Preview, we get to see a preview
of some recent posts
about Google Apps Script.
So this is just kind of rendered
here to make sure
that your search terms are
correct, and you're getting
the right kind of content.
And then from there, you can
just add that feed to your
feed library.
And then once it's in the
library, you have an RSS link
and a link straight to Google
Reader that will preloaded
that feed in Google
Reader for you.
And then just some additional
management to delete your
feeds if you no longer
want them.
IKAI LAN: So Eric, tell us about
some of the APIs you're
using to make this happen.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, so to render
this front end here
that we're taking a look at,
that's the HTML service which
we launched in Google
I/O this year.
So I'm using my own custom
HTML, CSS, JavaScript,
including a whole
lot of jQuery.
And I even integrated some
other JavaScript library
underscore, if people have
used that before.
I'm going to post more
about how that
integration works later on.
IKAI LAN: This is Eric's endless
Underscore evangelism.
You're going to hear
this about 10
times more in the future.
ERIC KOLEDA: I love
Underscore.
IKAI LAN: I'm not saying
it's bad, it's
just that, you know--
ERIC KOLEDA: I mean, jQuery is
great, but Underscore has some
cool power features too.
So that's what I used to render
this front end here.
And it's great, because with
the UI app in the past, you
were limited.
It was easy to set things up,
but you couldn't just do
whatever you wanted.
Here I have complete control
over the styles, the
JavaScript, the callbacks,
the flow, and feel of the
application.
And then, in addition, all this
information about the
feed library is stored
in ScriptDb, which
we mentioned earlier.
And it allows me to query on
just the feeds that I've
created, my own user, and it
also allows me to save and
retrieve the metadata associated
with these feeds.
So that was a really easy way
to store this data after I
created a feed.
And then the third major thing
I used was the Content
Service, which we just recently
published a new guide for.
The Content Service is what
allows me to serve an RSS feed
from Google Apps Script.
I can construct the XML inside
of the script, and then
publish it out, and then it's
consumable by Google Reader,
or theoretically other
feed readers.
IKAI LAN: Right.
One thing that we're asking, is
what do you do to get the
Google+ data, like what's the
API you're using, and what
complications do you run into.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
a good point.
So Google+ provides an API,
and I'm using the
unauthenticated version.
I actually just want to
have the public data.
Because the RSS feeds I'm
creating, in order to be
accessible by Google Reader,
they need to be
in the public domain.
Google Reader doesn't have your
credentials at the time
of the making of the request.
So because of that, I
wanted to limit this
to just public data.
I don't want anybody's private
data leaking out.
And so using the
unauthenticated, public
Google+ API, I use the URL fetch
app to build the URL,
and then got back the jSign
data which I parsed via
[? JSON.parse ?]
in my script.
So using those techniques,
I was able to
fetch data from Google+.
I'm using some caching too.
We have the Cache Service in
Apps Script that allows you
set a time on how long some
information should be cached.
So I made it so that if you keep
hitting Preview over and
over again, you're just going
to get the most recent data
for five minutes.
It's going to cache that data,
that way we're not overloading
the Google+ API, or running
out of quota there.
IKAI LAN: Cool.
Very, very cool.
ERIC KOLEDA: So this is in
the Chrome Web Store now.
You can kind of take a look
at it and try it out.
And I'm going to be publishing
a series of walkthroughs.
I haven't decided the format
yet, maybe textual, maybe
video, showing how the
technology behind this works,
and hopefully give you guys some
pieces that you can reuse
in your own scripts.
IKAI LAN: OK, very cool.
Thank you, Eric.
So why don't we move on to
some live questions?
So for those of you on the
Hangout, if you have any
questions about Eric's
application, or any of the
tools that he used, do feel free
to jump on and ask us.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right,
so do we have
anybody on the Hangout.
IKAI LAN: We've got--
looks like we've got one guy.
Hey there.
Hold on for a second, we're
going to get on
the moderator page.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right,
so if you have any
questions, come in later.
I'm going to pop up in the
moderator here, and re-share
so it can get a view of that.
Picture-in-picture here.
All right, here's the
Google Moderator.
So we've got some questions
here, but feel free to jump in
later if there are any
live questions.
So this one, top of the list
here, what is the best way to
store pictures with Google
Apps Script?
He needs to store about
3,000 jpeg photos and
1,000 PDFs every day.
And they must be protected from
the general public, but
accessible by his own
domain, and by
outside business partners.
IKAI LAN: Well the first thing,
Rudy, we're curious, do
you have 3,000 period?
Or do you need to add
3,000 photos a day?
That's quite a lot of photos.
And even though we try to make
our quotas pretty high, I feel
like you're going to trip some
kind of quota there.
ERIC KOLEDA: You've
been running--
you've been developing an app
that actually writes a lot to
Google Drive.
IKAI LAN: Right, right.
And we're trying to get Google
Drive [? right ?]
quota raised.
But 3,000 a day is going
to be pushing it.
That's a good question.
What do you think?
ERIC KOLEDA: I mean, I think
that Google Drive is
definitely the right place
to store these.
One way you may be able to get
around, or deal with the
quotas in Google Drive, if you
don't need each photo to be
individually in Drive, but
maybe zip them up.
And upload the whole zip to
Google Drive, that may count
as only one upload.
But then again, 3,000 photos
zipped may still be too large
for a single upload.
IKAI LAN: One thing that you
might be able to do is you
might be able to use ScriptDb.
And I believe you can pass a
[? blob ?] with ScriptDb.
I'm not exactly sure
how that works out.
But even if you can't,
I'm sure you've
can encode the blob.
But you're going to trip size
limits on the jpegs
themselves.
So I guess the big question
is, are you adding
3,000 jpegs a day?
Or is it just persistent roughly
3,000 with a few every
day coming in.
Because if you have a few coming
every day, probably
Google Drive is the
best way to go.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I would say, it definitely
doesn't sound like a use case
that is so far out of bounds.
I know you were talking to the
team about getting the
[? driveway ?]
[? codas ?] up.
So this is something that if
you can get us some more
background, we can make a
compelling case for why this
should be allowed
in Google Drive.
And we can talk to the
teams about that.
Great.
The next one we have here,
what steps are taken to
improve Google Apps Script
performance in terms of speed,
both pure JavaScript speed, as
well as key services like
spreadsheet service?
There is an issue in the issue
tracker he references here.
Can the engineering team focus
on that rather than new
features and services?
I know that performance has been
on the radar recently.
I've been working--
one of our engineers who,
they've been definitely taking
a look at the performance,
doing more
benchmarking, more testing.
And I think they have
some things that
they're looking into.
Obviously, we have
to balance both.
People wanted to keep doing more
and more with Google Apps
Script, and we want to make
sure that new compelling
things are possible.
But at the same time,
obviously, sometimes
performance can affect the
viability of an idea.
IKAI LAN: I think that
performance is really
important, but at least from a
priority standpoint, from my
perspective, in terms of pure
JavaScript performance, I'd
like to see a dashboard and some
login information before
I see pure JavaScript
performance.
So as many of you may know, the
JavaScript is interpreted
via [? Rhino. ?]
And a [? Rhino ?]
engine is fairly performant--
it runs on top of the JVM.
So if you're doing pure
computation, like, let's say
you're trying to calculate,
you're trying to factor the
product of large prime numbers,
that's going to be
hard on any kind of platform.
But we really need to understand
what part of
JavaScript performance
is killing you?
Are you creating lots and lots
of objects, really quickly,
and you need to get
rid of them?
And that should be fine
in JVM as well.
But we want to know what it is
in terms-- because there are
two parts here, right?
One is the pure JavaScript
and the
second part is the service.
The service, we definitely
need to improve the
performance on the service.
The pure JavaScript, we
like to know what
bottlenecks you run into.
Now--
ERIC KOLEDA: That's a key point,
because we want to make
everything faster, but only if
that fastness actually gives
real life benefit, right?
We want to make sure that all
the work we do produces
tangible results and
makes people's
lives actually better.
So if we cannot compute prime
numbers as fast as some other
platform, does that actually
affect whether or not you can
send an email in a workflow?
We want to make sure that
what we're doing
actually has impact.
But if there is a real impact
that you have, like an app
that's not working well because
of raw JavaScript
performance, leave that feedback
in the Issue Tracker.
IKAI LAN: There is one type of
issue where I think the raw
performance may be hindering
some people.
And I've heard about this from
some people, from you guys and
some folks on the core
engineering team, which is
regular expression parsing.
So if you have these types of
issues, do let us know because
we have seen this.
And it tends to be with very,
very long, large, complicated,
regular expressions, but these
problems do exist.
ERIC KOLEDA: I agree.
So the next one we have here is,
there's was a major outage
of HTML service this week
with continuing
issues coming from it.
Can you talk about the cause,
and the reliability of HTML
service, and any future steps
you're taken to improve it.
Some concerned customers.
So it is true that HTML service
was down a little bit,
was it yesterday, right?
It was down for about
half of a day.
ERIC KOLEDA: Half a day.
And it's certainly something
that everybody regretted and
felt bad about.
We're trying to keep all of
these services very stable.
And so one of the things we
especially looked at was,
getting the information out
there in a better way.
We do have a dashboard at
script.google.com/dashboard
that tells you about certain
services having problems and
their uptime more or less.
And unfortunately, HTML service
wasn't already baked
into that dashboard.
So we're looking at definitely
making sure that it's on there
as well as the other key
services, as well as maybe
adding additional information
to that dashboard.
So that's one thing that we're
definitely looking into.
IKAI LAN: We're also talking
about different ways of doing
notification.
There's one way is to put
it on the dashboard.
But some of the other things we
can do is actively notify
developers.
Because the thing about HTML
service is that we knew it was
happening, so we could have
notify developers.
But the best we could do at
this point was to post
something into Issues Tracker
and try to answer questions as
quickly as we could see them.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
a good point.
We did post on the Issue
Tracker as well.
Which is a good way to
get the follow up
on when it was resolved.
If there are other ways that
you prefer to be contacted,
give us that feedback.
If you are on Google+ let us
know if there's another medium
that works better for you.
All right, we have two
more questions here.
Any news on a West
Coast Hackathon?
IKAI LAN: Rudy, possibly,
just stay tuned.
I see that you're
from Phoenix.
So I don't want to let too many
cats out of the bag right
now, but how close are
you to Los Angeles?
What?
Am I-- too much information?
ERIC KOLEDA: Purely
hypothetical.
IKAI LAN: Purely hypothetical.
Just stay tuned, pay attention
to our blog
and our Google+ posts.
There's one coming, and we'd
really like to invite you out
to see what you're doing.
ERIC KOLEDA: 3,000
photos per day.
Yeah, Rudy followed up here,
3,000 photos per day.
IKAI LAN: Well I've got
one, and I've got
one which might work.
But I have to talk
to some folks,
which is Google Storage.
Google Storage is meant
primarily as cloud storage for
developers.
And the quota there
is completely
based on what you pay.
So with Apps Script right now,
we do we don't have different
quota tiers that you can pay
because you don't pay for
Google Apps Script.
So we don't really have a good
way of giving you additional
storage scalability.
However, Google Storage
already has billing.
This is [? something ?]
enabled API console.
We need to figure out how to
make that work nicely with
Google Apps Script.
It should work using
URL fetch.
But some of the stuff
is doing--
you've got to go through
[INAUDIBLE] flow and push
things out.
And I don't think anyone has
written any sample code
showing how to do that yet.
ERIC KOLEDA: The other nice
thing about Drive is the other
half of the question there was
like, how do you get it so
that it's hidden from the
public, but accessible within
a domain and outside
business partners.
Our Drive is great at
doing permissions.
It's very easy to invite people
and have things exposed
to your domain.
So we'll have to see what's the
best fit between handling
a lot of data, because
Google Storage is
meant for tons of data.
IKAI LAN: Right, that's true.
ERIC KOLEDA: You're kind of
right at that threshold where
you're going from a little bit
of data to a lot of data.
IKAI LAN: Right.
Google Storage, also, I don't
believe you can have-- you
have either public
or private ACLs.
And I don't think it gets any
more complex than that, which
could be a problem.
But the thing about the ACLs is
that a lot of people just
go by security by obscurity,
which is that it's very hard
for people to guess that URL.
Right?
A lot of people do do this.
It depends on the sensitivity
of the images, I suppose.
ERIC KOLEDA: That could
influence a decision for sure.
All right, great.
That seems to be all the
things we have on the
moderator page.
Do we have anybody
else in the live
Hangout that has questions?
IKAI LAN: We probably should
have bounced back and forth
between the moderator and
the live Hang Out.
ERIC KOLEDA: Let me quit my
screen sharing, a little
picture and picture here.
All right.
Let's see, checking the chat,
there is something in the chat
we have here too.
John Coffman asks, sample app
is too small to be seen.
Oh, sorry about that.
Yeah, we were trying to make it
so that the resolution was
a little better here.
But like I said, it is in the
Chrome Web Store, search for
Feed Plus and you can also
take a look at it there.
And then he also had a question
about time stamping
to look at the logger at
millisecond resolution so I
can test various architectures
of my code.
IKAI LAN: So there are a couple
different ways you can
do this, right.
And they're all a little
bit flawed.
So the question is, how can I
test which parts of my code
tend to be slower than others.
And this is going to be a little
bit tricky because the
logger right now it's
not persistent.
And what you can do
is, you can--
it's easy enough to collect
the time in terms of
milliseconds at the beginning of
when you start an API call
and at the end.
Now the question is, how do
you collect this data?
And honestly, this is only
useful if you run it over and
over and over, like a large
amount of time.
And one thing you can
do is, you could
store it into ScriptDb.
But the problem with the
ScriptDb solution is that now
you have-- well no, the ScriptDb
solution works just
fine, because you're doing
it right after
you collect the time.
ERIC KOLEDA: After you
collect the time--
IKAI LAN: I was going to say,
well by observing it, you're
influencing how long it takes.
But if you write it--
ERIC KOLEDA: We're getting
into quantum physics
there, aren't we?
IKAI LAN: Yeah, we're getting
into Heisenberg uncertainty
principle and all that.
And that's all I know
about physics.
I just know that phrase.
Yeah that's one thing that a
lot of people do, that one
thing that we do.
We don't have a benchmarking
tool built in yet.
We haven't seen a lot of
requests for this, because
typically what we--
a lot of our developers, what
they look for are things on
how can we reduce the runtime
of this from the order of 10
seconds to an order of three
or four seconds.
As opposed to this thing runs in
20 milliseconds, I want it
to run in 10 milliseconds.
That's going to be a little
bit trickier.
What do you think?
ERIC KOLEDA: I mean, definitely
I think that
[? there's ?] definitively
a lot of interest
in performance today.
We've got a lot of questions
about performance.
So I think, obviously, the more
we could do to provide
tools to benchmark
that the better.
And obviously you had some good
suggestions there for
making your own.
But I think that it could be
worthwhile that if people are
really looking at like max
performance, maybe we look at
providing some more
of those tools.
We can talk to the
team about that.
IKAI LAN: Right, right.
And, yeah, I mean I definitely
have seen, for instance, HTML
service performance has been
improving very quickly.
I've seen that the core
engineering team has been
rolling out a lot of
updates for that.
ERIC KOLEDA: For sure.
We have another question here
in the chat from one of our
participants, asks is there any
documentation on client
side use of JavaScript
and HTML service?
Like the limitations that
the [? Kaha engine ?]
has for JavaScript.
So I know we do have a page that
kind of lists some of the
basic restrictions.
It's our tutorial--
not [? tutorial ?] but our guide
on the HTML service.
I think it's under User
Interfaces in
our Navigation Structure.
And in there, we talk
about some of them.
But we are realizing that there
are some things you'd be
used to doing in a regular HTML
web app that in [? Kaha ?]
get a bit challenging.
I know today one of our
colleagues just ran into a
problem with onClick.
Setting that on an element
had some strange behavior
depending upon what
you're doing.
So we're looking at figuring
out more of what those
challenges are and coming
up with solutions.
I think the onClick one did have
one solution buried into
the documentation already.
So I think if you give that
another read, maybe do some
Control F, find the word
you're looking for.
There may be something
already in there.
IKAI LAN: There's a tool too
that Corey mention that was
useful, which is [? Kaha ?]
what was it?
[? Kaha ?]
Code runner, Script
runner, sandbox?
Sandbox.
Where what you can do is, if you
just want to run one piece
of code and see if it works, you
can run it in a [? Kaha ?]
Sandbox.
But [? Kaha ?]
is known for being a little bit
overly restrictive, erring
on the side of caution.
So things that are malformed are
going to cause problems.
You were talking about
this last week.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah,
that bit me once.
IKAI LAN: What was the
specific thing?
Yeah,
ERIC KOLEDA: The specific one
was you create an object
literal in JavaScript, like open
squiggly, close squiggly,
and key value pairs.
After every key value pair you
had a comma to separate them,
but you're not supposed
to have a comma on
the very last one.
It's only to separate them
at the end of every one.
And if you had that comma, web
browsers usually don't care
but [? Kaha ?] cared and
it caused a problem.
IKAI LAN: Web browsers
don't care.
I think [? Kaha ?] is also
specific about named keywords,
but I could be wrong
about that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah,
there may be some
limitations there as well.
The main idea is that [? Kaha ?]
is trying to keep
things safe, right?
They're going on more
of a whitelist
style approach, right?
They know what's good
JavaScript, and they're making
you stick to that.
And if you try to go outside
those rounds, you might be
doing something fishy, you might
trying to break out of
the Sandbox, they
don't want that.
IKAI LAN: So we've been kind
of neglecting the live
audience who's been
patiently waiting.
Why don't we jump to some live
audience members and see
what's going on.
Are you guys just kind of
just watching the show?
ERIC KOLEDA: Rudy, John,
any live questions.
IKAI LAN: Oh it that Rudy?
RUDY: Yes.
IKAI LAN: Hi, Rudy.
Sorry I don't mean to help
you jump the line.
John, you've been patiently
waiting since the beginning of
the Hangout.
How are you doing?
It looks like he's going
to type, no microphone.
That's probably where
he's going to go.
Rudy, back to you.
Rudy: I don't know.
I'm trying to use Twitter
Bootstrap with HTML service,
and I'm running into a little
bit of a problem with
[? Kaha. ?]
Any plans of allowing
a bit of Bootstrap?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, Joe actually
just did a Plus post
about this today.
I think it--
was it you, the one
who created it?
RUDY: No, I wasn't.
ERIC KOLEDA: OK.
So there was someone actually
already out there.
I actually wasn't that familiar
with a Twitter Bootstrap.
But it seems like it's basically
a framework, a
pre-built framework.
IKAI LAN: It's very cool.
And before you go on, how did
you find out about this post?
ERIC KOLEDA: Via Google+ in
my RSS feed, you mean?
IKAI LAN: All right, continue.
ERIC KOLEDA: But, yeah.
So someone had already actually
created kind of like
a working example version of
it in Apps Script, but said
they didn't have time
to develop it.
So check my Plus feed, then you
can take a look at what
they've done so far.
But I would imagine there
would be challenges.
When you're taking JavaScript,
and I've run into this myself,
that's been developed like a
library, even a very popular
library, there's usually
a lot of hands in it.
And it's usually not 100%
accurate to the specification.
And so in those cases,
[? Kaha ?]
is going to cause
some problems.
RUDY: Yeah, actually the
challenge is the CSS.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, you
can't [? import ?]
CSS.
And there is a JavaScript
performance tip, a while ago,
I know [? Kaha ?] will
definitely not allow this,
where if use document dot
[? write ?] to write a script
tag into your increase
your performance.
I know, I know.
I know we're going into really
bare metal stuff.
But there are a lot of really
crazy things that people do to
make their libraries
really zip along.
And [? Kaha ?] is not
going to like that.
The CSS, that's a
good question.
We don't allow imports
of external CSS yet.
And I don't know
if we will be.
ERIC KOLEDA: You can definitely
bake it into your
Apps Script.
But even then, I know there are
some issues today that we
were still investigating around
styling the body tag,
for instance, that's one we've
had problems with.
And I think there was someone I
talked to recently too, that
there's a CSS positioning which
is not relative not
fixed, fixed positioning, and
that is not allowed by
[? Kaha. ?]
Because I think, once again,
[? Kaha is ?] about embedding
within another app.
And you don't want your
ideas flying around.
IKAI LAN: That makes sense.
So let's say you're embedding
your application in someone
else's sites page.
If you use fixed position, you
could theoretically position
over a Google my account, or
log out, which really just
sends you to some crazy phishing
site or whatever.
ERIC KOLEDA: In the context of
a web app, where you have the
whole screen to yourself, some
of these don't make quite as
much sense.
But it is part of the
[? Kaha ?] engine.
And we can talk to the team
about if there's ways to
disable bits here and there.
But for the most part, the
things that [? Kaha ?] does,
it has a reason for.
But it does create some problems
when you just want to
dump a whole bunch of code
in and run with it.
When you are head building it,
you can kind of handle these
one at a time and take
them into account.
But when you are bringing in an
extra library or framework,
it can be challenging.
IKAI LAN: It seems like that's
something that comes up a lot,
which is the look
and feel thing.
Twitter Bootstrap, I've
used it before,
it's pretty neat stuff.
I've used it for some
of my demos before.
It's pretty cool.
It's too bad, well, your sites
all look like Twitter.
But it solves a lot
of problems.
And in fact, that new JavaScript
library, Yeoman,
y-e-o-m-a-n, it does, there's
a Twitter Bootstrap.
ERIC KOLEDA: Plug-in for it?
IKAI LAN: I want to
say bootstrap.
There's a Twitter Bootstrap
bootstrap.
It's very cool stuff.
So if you are building web
apps outside Apps Script,
definitely check out Yeoman.
I think it's y-e-o-m-an,
I don't
remember, it's yeoman.io.
It's very cool.
They've got this demo where
you're editing code in an
editor and when you hit Save,
it updates the browser.
I guess it's using browser
channel, it's
using it to push updates.
ERIC KOLEDA: It'd be cool to see
if maybe we could talk to
them about maybe integrating
with Apps Script someday.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, I'd love
to get those guys to do
free work for us.
So I think we're running
out of time.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, just
about out of time.
IKAI LAN: You guys don't know
this but our producer today is
Jan, and she's hiding
in the back.
So she's actually just giggling
at us and just making
fun of us the whole time.
Trying to make us
laugh on camera.
But she's doing a great
job producing, and
she's warning us that--
ERIC KOLEDA: Time is
just about up.
So we had some great questions
and answers today.
Thanks everybody who came in
for joining us, and for the
moderator questions
ahead of time.
If you have anything else that
you have questions about,
stack overflow, the Issue
Tracker for bugs, or reach out
to us on Google+.
IKAI LAN: That's about it.
All right, take everyone.
It was good to see you.
ERIC KOLEDA: Thank you.
IKAI LAN: Or for
you to see us.
ERIC KOLEDA: Bye bye.